hélas berne
58 ans
contre l'agression ma délégation au sein
du département sauces et les personnes
âgées
aimé tu perds ton pas c'est qu'elle
tient compte des concessions l'une des
bambous ravine des cabris bois d'olives
pierrefonds est une partie des nih
paraty
mon attachement
dans ce canton c'est que je fais où je
suis né et j'ai toujours vécu à la
ravine des cabris à ce que j'aimerais
améliorer dans le canton 20 c'est déjà
sur l'éradication des ravines c'est une
chose qui me tient à coeur même si sa
relève pas forcément bas de la fonction
de la délégation mais aussi
améliorations au niveau des personnes
âgées surtout au niveau de l'habitat
insalubre
les missions du département vont de la
petite enfance de sachets
pour les drames comme c'est ma
délégation
c'est de les garder un maximum à
domicile
je ne dis pas qu'il ne faut pas
construire des étables et de neymar mais
aussi ce qu'il faut c'est peut-être
lutter contre l'habitat insalubre et
surtout essayer au maximum
d'améliorer leur cadre de vie
je me suis engagé en politique
justement pour lutter
contre la misère sociale qui régnait